zatia --nz writer Christopher Hitchens
and Sharon Waxman who's written a book
on lost art are two of the panelists
this is about an hour and 15 minutes
thank you good afternoon everyone I'm
Tom collage of the New York Times and it
is my great pleasure to welcome you to
the time center for our eighth annual
Arts and Leisure weekend over the next
hour we explore one of the most pressing
cultural questions of our time namely
where do the great treasures of ancient
art rightfully belong we are privileged
to be joined by three renowned experts
on this subject whose work whether as
journalists authors scholars or leaders
of some of the world's great art
institutions has done much to shed light
on this topic you will hear much more
about these esteemed panelists from our
moderator as the New York Times culture
reporter covering classical music and
dance
he has reported on everything from the
New York Philharmonic
historic trip to North Korea last spring
to Elliott Carter's centennial birthday
concert at Carnegie Hall last month this
past year he's also chronicled the
exploits of Gerard Maurier leaving New
York City Opera classical music patron
Alberto Villar being sent to jail and on
a lighter note the distracted virtuosity
who have inexplicably left their
multi-million dollar musical instruments
behind in taxi cabs trains restrooms and
even front doorsteps please join me in
welcoming our moderator dan waken and
our special guests James Q no
Christopher Hitchens and Sharon Waxman
hello everybody it's good to be here I
lost my voice this morning so that means
don't have to talk more than me
hopefully cool so we're going to talk a
bit about works of art and artifacts in
museums and where they came from how
they got there and should they stay or
should they go the jumping-off point is
Sharon's book loot which is sort of a
comprehensive look at various issues and
in reading it I came up with sort of two
categories of works one things that were
dug up torn away removed in the early
19th century early 20th century brought
to the great museums in Paris London New
York and have become part of those
museums and sort of part of the fabric
of that the other category are objects
that have been found in recent years
things that have been suddenly emerged
on the market in 1980 1990 and find
their way into museums and are the
subject of a different kind of
controversy so I thought we'd start out
with the first category and we have some
slides and a I'm going to show a series
of three slides if we can go through one
two and three and then maybe Sharon can
talk a little bit about what they are
and why they're important sure well I
think to put the the issues of category
1 and category 2 which is objects that
were looted or plundered otherwise
appropriated the past 200 years ago 150
years ago are in fact connected to these
restitution battles that we're seeing
emerge on the front pages or the culture
pages of newspapers and journals and
magazines today which is when you have
these countries that were the where
these things were dug up they're called
source countries that are now demanding
things back you have to really go back
to the origins of the plunder or of the
origins of the creation the core
creation of the great collections of our
great museums to understand what's at
the heart of this which is what the book
tries to do so a great example of this
is Egypt because Egypt
literally some people call it the rape
of Egypt there's a wonderful book called
the rape of the Nile by Brian Figgins
one of the early books on the topic that
talk about there's the kind of
free-for-all of a you know just grab
fest that Egypt became in in the 19th
century after Napoleon invaded and
conquered and then lost it to the
British and his he had a military
purpose of course for doing so but in
the course of doing that he just he
brought ancient Egypt to the eyes of
Europe which had kind of been aware of
the Wonder the wondrous beauty of
ancient Egypt that we're all kind of
familiar with every day the Sphinx the
pyramids were these were very vague
notions to Europeans at that time so
just to give you an example of the kind
of outrages essentially that happened in
the 19th century in Egypt I was given
access to by by Egypt's chief
archaeologist his name is aji Hawass if
you see anything Egyptian you've seen
the guy yes it's Indiana Jones hat and
he's constantly very passionately
excited talking about all the beauties
of Egypt and what they discovered and
it's usually right before some Discovery
Channel special starring him on
television but anyway part of the fact
that he loves being in the media he's
right there's a lot of stuff out there
that that was taken that was taken in
kind of horrifying ways that we're not
aware about aware of it so he gave me
access to all of the tombs in the Valley
of the Kings which is where the pharaohs
were buried you probably know that this
particular tomb is the tomb of Amon opus
three it has never been open to the
public and I took this photograph in
pitch-black love my camera but you can
just see that's that I really thanks to
digital technology that was able to get
this image this is look at how beautiful
and of course this is not the most you
know if we have light in the tomb you
see how vivid the colors are on opus 3
one of the great Pharaoh's and this is
him side by side with various gods
Anubis etc and we can see the next this
slide and then the next one please
you can see how somebody came into the
19th century and just cut out three of
the heads of the Pharaoh boom boom boom
boom
and then let's we don't know exactly who
cut them out but what we do know is that
today next slide please
they are in the Louvre and that is the
that is the head of one of those three
and all three of them are in the Louvre
you can go see them today they're in the
Sully wing so you know Zahi Hawass has
asked for five major pieces back from
western museums including the Boston
Museum of Fine Arts the Louvre the
British Museum and two German museums
this is not these these heads are not
among the pieces that he's asked for but
you just get a sense of the feeling of
dispo Lee a ssin that Egyptians who are
passionate about archaeology in their
past feel when when the subject arises
let's give another example of that
number four please Sharon tell us what
this shows so this is actually one of
the objects that Zahi Hawass does walk
back this is the zodiac ceiling or that
wood that's the replica it's a that
black blobby thing and the top is a
black plaster cast that the loop sent to
the to Egypt in the 19th century after I
was saying archaeologist and adventurer
and his agent Jean Jacques sold me a
spent 21 days hacking this ceiling out
of the temple of dendara
which is this stunning temple that
stands in the middle of these marshes
the Nile used to flow right up to it
it's toothed it's 2,000 years old and it
is one of the earliest recorded zodiacs
that we have so if you were to see it
better well if you see it as it was
actually drawn Institute before it was
blasted out of there by Napoleon's
scientists who came with it you could
really see you can see Scorpio and Libra
you can actually see recorded in Eclipse
at a certain time in about 2000 about
about about just before the birth of
Christ essentially so it's it's really
an amazing piece of history in addition
to being an artifact and it's in the
today it took 21 days for the French to
hack it out of the sea out of the
ceiling which is on the roof
of the temple of dendera they finally
used gunpowder to blast it out and
that's how they got the thing to France
let me ask Jimbo as a museum director
should these kinds of artifacts be
returned to Egypt well first I think we
have to recognize that history is an
untidy is untidy and it's a complicated
situation in this case it's not just
that and I'm looking down here because
we can actually see the images here in
front of us but it's not just that the
that this period of time in the latter
part of the 18th century early part of
the 19th century was a time in which the
Europeans became interested in things
ancient in Egypt but it's also at a time
in which by virtue of the Europeans
becoming interested in those things then
that the local peoples became interested
as well they had lived for centuries
then amongst these things but of course
they reasonably believed that the values
of their civilization call it began with
with the Prophet with a prophet Muhammad
and that these pagan artifacts had no
relationship to the life they lived or
the civilization that they claimed for
themselves so it wasn't it wasn't this
was something that was prized and as
glory of the ancient die of the current
Egyptians when that when the French and
the British were there it was something
came upon later and in fact the first as
it were local history of ancient Egypt
was written by an Egyptian who had
studied in France and got caught up in
the kind of fervor of nationalism in in
Paris and sweeping Europe in the middle
part of the 19th century so it is not
its history is never so neat and tidy as
we would like it to be and these
questions of restitution are also
questions about how and on what terms
might we rewrite history they're based
on the premise that there's a way to
correct the imbalances historical
imbalances of power we want to redress
them in some way now so I don't I don't
think there's a claim for these objects
from and using them generally speaking
that were removed prior to their laws
being against their removal others we
can now go back and say this is 180
years before Egypt passed such a law so
there's no legal reason why they might
be returned there is a moral reason
that's the question is there more reason
on what terms might there be moral
reason
there's moral reason because there's
some claim that the modern state of
Egypt has on the remains of an ancient
civilization from which they have long
been divorced to which they have no
other contact than physical proximity
and only more or less physical proximity
because the Egyptian Empire of course
was spread much greater than the current
Egyptian state I think the complication
and it's raised in the question asked of
this symposium do these things belong to
the to the civilizations that create
them first of all there's a big debate
in question whether civilizations create
anything or whether it's people who
create things and then we put them
together in the framework we call
civilizations but whether there is you
can map a civilization to the confines
of a current state and I think that
those are unequal political realities
civilization is not political and those
terms we're talking about it
the state is political and they don't
even share the same geographic same
boundaries no geographical boundary so I
don't see there's a claim I think the
only way these things can be returned is
because it's to the advantage of the
current possessor of these now that in
other words when the partner marbles
that christopher's written powerfully on
it will they be returned to Athens only
I think if the British government thinks
it's in its own best interest to do so I
don't think it's going to be on moral
grounds it's not going to be on our
historical or scientific grounds I think
it's a matter of public and political
diplomacy
what you're saying is that the British
then if it's in their interest they
should return the marbles because they
happen to have no no I'm saying they
will do so only when it is in their
interest I'm not saying should they
should do so I'm just saying it that's
the political reality of the situation
there isn't a legal claim upon them as
there's no legal claim on this that can
be decided it can only be because the
possessor current possessor thinks it's
in their best interest to do so well the
but not usurp your function mr. Chandler
please I read the question I was hoping
you would ask was would there be such a
thing as aesthetic grounds if we're
discussing art I think the aesthetic
should have a role in it and the case in
the
the instance of the Parthenon the
sculpture of the Parthenon is precisely
that the committee that I'm a member of
in London used to call the committee for
the restitution of both normal it's now
called the committee for the
reunification of them and I just like to
say if I can't a few words about how
that neurons matters and the the
sculpture of phidias that adorns the
this magnificent building would did used
to adore it
um these carved as a unity it tells a
story it's probably derived from the
Panther night procession there are all
kinds of interpretations about how many
numbers of human figures there are in it
and whether they are the equivalent of
the Greek casualties of a certain famous
battle and so forth but at any rate it
doesn't make much sense to have one half
of them in Athens and one half in London
you can't move the whole of the
Parthenon to London to Bloomsbury but if
for example during the Napoleonic Wars
the the panel of the Mona Lisa have been
as did happen to quite a lot of
artifacts annexed plundered are then
sawn in half by somebody and we knew
that one half of it was in a gallery in
Stockholm and another in the gallery in
Lisbon I'm pretty sure there would be a
mass movement of aesthetic curiosity to
see what the two hulls would look like
if they were put together and probably
the strong guess could be made they'd
look better than they do sort well I
think the same can be said that she has
to be said over the Parthenon sculptures
now there are not very many examples of
that there Jones just given you and
particularly vivid and beautiful and if
I may say so very beautifully
illustrated it seems to be perfectly
clear the Louvre or to say it's a matter
of aesthetic wholeness and integrity
disability on the wings I mean I do
think the Mona Lisa the example is in
not not appropriate in a situation or
not relevant because the assumption is
that you would have the entire thing and
it would be split in two parts and would
come back together the entire thing and
if that were the case likely it would be
resolved on those terms and the two
museums would share them that would be
the luck that happens many times in this
case and in the case of the Parthenon
Marbles they
the partner bubbles as you know very
well would not be restored in their
entirety
there would be fragments of them
restored and there would be great gaucho
if we have slide 30 please and and so
there and that's the first questions
then it's not going to be restoring the
integrity of the Parthenon itself or of
its sculptured program but secondly if
there's been no suggestion and there's
it would be very difficult to do this to
share the entirety between Athens and
London and it's not just London after
all you know among London's got the
largest bits of the Parthenon Marbles
outside of Athens but they're also in
other places in Europe and so forth so
it's it's not quite as easy there are
most of the smaller holders have have
given we're all giving ya that exact
because the Acropolis Museum you're
quite right in saying that the they
can't be put back on the building and
that also some of them have been lost
hold the entire thing can't be restored
but you will be able very soon to see
the whole of the sculpture of videos in
one place we would be if the British
government would in in a gallery that
overlooks the that looks at the pond
idea and it's nearest you'll be able to
get to a restitution would not have your
choice so it could let's make a relation
point which is about the rights of the
show called for now the indigenous if
there doesn't sound too colonial I mean
the the Napoleonic expedition to Egypt
was a classical orientalist expedition
but it was not just for pillage it was
for enlightenment for anthropology he
attached his frisian Hasani and he's
number of scholars mapmakers and so
forth actually was credited by many
Egyptians with having so dynamized what
had been a very stagnant province of the
Ottoman Empire in convulsions that may
was into the modern world for example
there was a Napoleonic officers name was
sham polio who came across a stone in
the sand
sort of try a three-sided bar one bar
bore Egyptian hieroglyphics in one other
bar board Greek and I think that had few
demonic demonic intronic where it was
fairly easy to work out from that how to
decode Egyptian hieroglyphics there's no
Gyptian new heart
because the Egyptians of that stage went
were Arabs this they're part of the Arab
conquest system every bit of every bit
as alien and outside is the is the
Islamic art conquest as would have the
French or British one have been now this
question is who are we dealing with in
the case of Greece it is to borrow TS
Eliot's wonderful expression which is if
itself taken from James Joyce it's in
after strange gods the same people
living in the same place roughly you can
say the inhabitants of Attica that their
language is pretty much recognizable in
Greek and that it's being spoken in the
same city on the same peninsula as verse
videos and Sophocles so that seems a
rather stronger claim but why isn't any
Egyptian claim because I think I think
that's perfectly okay the rosetta stone
is in the British Museum should stay
there I don't think it's not a sense
trip I don't believe that's up to us to
tell the people who live in the borders
where these ancient civilizations
physically exist that they are not the
heirs to that civilization why not the
reason why there's a couple of reasons
why one is it's not up to us to do
genetic testing on people and to say
well you're not actually the genetic
heir and therefore it's not on the
nation's it would make that I have had
so many people write to me since this
book has come out and during the
research of this book and make the most
racist kinds of remarks along those
lines so that that's sort of where the
conversations to say there are no more
than say there are no more Babylonians
neurology men were Assyrians there
aren't any no one can make a claim
saying this is ours that would be the
race I'm sure the racist claim is the
one but the your dentist races we're not
the one that says we we are we are these
people it is not a racist claim I don't
think the comments that have been made
here at all but it's racialist in a
sense that it puts it in a racial
context and ties the connection or the
or the the legitimacy of the claim to
whether or not those people are actual
the heirs of that civilization to me
that sort of falls in the category of
there are no Palestinians back in the
ancient arab-israeli conflict well that
you know they don't there is no such
thing as a Palestinian which Golda Meir
famously said I mean if the Egyptians
there's an important issue here which is
the civil is the
to those civilizations who physically
live among them are ultimately
responsible for the care of those
artifacts if we are trying to convince
them that they are not really connected
to those things then they can say well
we don't care about them and they'll
allow them to deteriorate and be
destroyed and that and I think there is
an audience what we think is that are
they pardon me
they notice obedient to what we say or
we think as all that well
that's true that's true too and happily
so but if we're trying to undermine the
sent their sense of connection to that
then that is ultimately a self-defeating
a way of thinking for all of us who
cherish these treasures because
ultimately the people in Turkey are
going to have to take the most care of
the antiquities that are in their
physical ji4 what if I can't
what if they can't before that night
that's true
- and Sharon has a good story about that
but the question of civilization and
Turkey's a perfect example of this
because what is the civilization that is
there I mean is it Greek is it Roman is
it is it Ottoman is it modern Republican
Turkish how does one map this thing if
you think that the great things ought to
be returned to with the Greeks Greek
civilization well it turns out that of
course for hundreds of years the
southern part of Italy was a colony of
Greece Magna Grecia
or mega Ellis the greater Greece and so
those things that are then in the
southern part of Italy they'd be turned
to Greece because there are Greeks now
if there is a source or I can also tell
very easily okay then do let me I can
save you some time okay well if you
answer briefly but I'll get on to my
second but I'll get to my second point
very quickly that if there is some say
racial link between these things that
one can call if you can if these things
are imprinted with Greek nests and some
profound way and they therefore on those
terms ought to be with Greeks Greeks
don't only live in Athens or don't only
live in Greece in fact Greeks live in
London and so if there's a claim that
they should be in the company of Greeks
Greeks live all around the world and
therefore these things ought to be all
around the world it is to the benefit on
those terms of weeks that they should be
in the company of this where they live
III just think that those are kinds and
what about non Greeks who live in Greece
well
promised I was going to make this easy
for you the government in people of
Greece have never demanded the return of
anything except the Parthenon novel
Wilbur remained with the half of the
Parthenon sculpture wrongly called Elgin
it has to be called Elgin under the
under the terms under which Parliament I
think he legally bought the sculpture
the organ family insisted they have to
be called that in the collection the
profit on model can we tonight why do
they only ask for the return of that
well first I'll say why they don't ask
for anything else they because it's what
one reason you give mega at the last
large parts of Anatolia what's now Izmir
Smyrna large parts of Italy and so forth
were once part of Greece that's the
first thing the second thing is no
Museum of Civilization anywhere in the
world it was imported to show our
civilization as humans evolved would be
complete without some Greek artifacts
and the Greeks think that that's
excellent they want there to be Greek
sculpture all over the world in diaspora
like this it's just that it makes no
sense to have half of a unified piece of
sculpture there's a piece of literature
as well as if you subscription tells a
story in one place especially when it
comes from what can be reason to be
called the National temple of the Greece
now the National occasional example the
National Temple of the people of Egypt
is not the pyramids it's do not have a
temple of ancient Egyptian civilization
before the Arab and Muslim conquest
which it isn't symbolic in the least
well you can't move the pyramids happily
so that's alright but the point of the
National Temple of Greece is when an
Christopher's book is powerful on this
but you have to remember that the
history of this of this just this part
in this temple this temple was a Greek
temple as we think of it today for a
number of years it was for equal number
of years a Christian Church it was for
equal number of years a mosque it was
the it was blown up by the Venetians
the mosque was no longer usable in those
terms so they created a second smaller
mosque on the site when finally the
Greeks won independence from the
Ottomans they created a kingdom with a
17-year old Bavarian king who hired his
father's favorite architect the Bavarian
architect LaVon Cleanser whom you all
know from
central part of Munich to create the
national symbol the National Temple that
Krampus and the Parthenon and he gave
this great speech in the company of of
the 70 year old Bavarian king who said
that aren't you on the on this sacred
land we have removed all the emblems of
barbarity from it because the first
thing they had to do to create a
national temple was to get rid of all
the accretions of the Byzantines and of
them of the of the Ottomans the church
in 20 a 23 please and so so when when
these national monuments are made they
are literally made it's a political act
it's not a cultural act it's not an
historical is not a scientific act that
was made an historic Center historic
temple of modern Greece after all it was
Athenian it wasn't you know wasn't
Spartan it wasn't another city-states
monument Jim wasn't anyone and also it's
a temple to religion that's also yeah
right
if the sculptures were in Athens today
you wouldn't suggest that they be
removed to another place so they'd be so
they could be shared with the world or
shared with other Greeks you know what I
think Chris is more for we're all for it
III think that we ought to be arguing I
think we're we ought to be ought to be
arguing more about how it is that we can
work to share the world's artistic
legacy with the world all right I agree
with that but I think that there's so
many self-serving arguments that come
from the museum world about these issues
and what happened to the Parthenon it's
all very genteel and very and very
civilized today but what happened at the
time was a really violent act actually I
mean you had Lord elegance people
hacking the sculptures off the top you
see it along the rim of the building
which is now empty they've all been
taken down because of the pollution they
can't be outside anymore but the the
meta peas were they were hacked out and
this was actually you could there's no
really valid legal argument but you
really there are legal people who like
to argue about it because it seems
pretty clear if you read the deparment
that was given him at the time that he
absolutely breached the limits that he's
supposed to take the sculptures that
were on the ground and from day one they
started hacking at the building I think
if you we if we don't kind of bring
those parts of history into the open you
can't really talk honestly about what is
the right thing to do with these with
these sculptures today we all we all
believe that we should preserve them we
all believe that we should share them we
all believe that we want them to be
available as many people as possible all
of those are values that have to be
balanced with recognizing history
placing it in context the integrity of
the building itself as a piece of
artwork as a as a piece of history and
as a symbol of what is the what we all
look back to in Western civilization as
the kind of the beginnings of democracy
itself I mean there those are all values
that have to be balanced but I think
that we can't just pretend that what
happened to the Parthenon at the hands
of colonial empires and a very you know
obsessive lore who was a diplomat and an
envy of the British Empire is it was not
a very violent act
yeah we're not right why isn't that
enough just to be open what if all
museums just said you gave the complete
truth about the acquisitions
I don't believe they'll do let's say
they did though would that be enough and
would able to solve I'm not the decider
here so I think that the place to start
the British Museum does a very good job
of being very clear and transparent
about the history of these objects and I
have to say that you know we have to
recognize and alguns associates who
remove these things and we don't have
the the actual firm and the actual
document we got because where it isn't
in the book they've got the Italian
translation that's held privately by a
British citizen so we don't we're not
really close enough to understand what
the original document was and what
license it was given to his associates
but they just didn't do this overnight I
mean this took weeks and weeks to serve
tisha stay here and so if there if they
wanted this not to happen if somebody
wanted this not to happen it could have
been prevented you know it wasn't
something that just stilled on what the
Greeks pointed out there is that Athens
at that point was under foreign
occupation now I don't know if I thought
about chuckle authorities who regarded
as a row that we were rather back with
Providence ascending for the most part
didn't care about the greatness
heritage so they were legitimately the
Ottoman says some years to go before
it's independent but legally yes but
that's why it does matter I think that
it's very clear that elegant over Dover
is hermitage we say the terms of what he
being allowed to take away some some
stones some small stones of little value
I think are the ones that are mentioned
first then of course you the birds on
which he takes them back to England gets
sunk the first shipment thank you
that could have been all she wrote does
it happens this possible recovers though
it might very well we have to think
which is why I argue for the
distribution of things because you want
to distribute the risk to them if they
were all in one place be that one place
London or Berlin 1945 or or New York and
9/11 or bag data or Kabul today you're
concentrating the risk the risk of their
extraordinary destruction destruction a
great deal of them is great if you
distribute them all in the world you
stupid the risk is really I've already
said that I agree with you about that as
do the government of people of Greece
they want agreed Jasper of sculpture but
I can't think that I really understood
you correctly when well that you
understood chance question correctly
when she said if the whole sculpture the
Parthenon was now in Athens and had
never been that you would still be in
favor of having it a partitioning isn't
a division well limbs burry in well in
this case first of all you know that the
place was a wreck and ruin before Elgin
came to it but let's assume that it was
pristine and everything that was made
for it was still on it no one would ever
argue for its removal from an art from
an architectural monument you would
argue instead for portable objects to be
shared and distributed so that's the
clarify but but in this case it was
never know that you can come in splendid
you know the exhibition is constantly on
the move
yeah anything is mobile and portable
absolutely but in this case the
hypothetical is you know is only that I
mean it had not been an entire monument
for a thousand years yes before elegant
it had been a ruin for 200 years before
elven for sure but it had been
Church had been a model it's been all
kind of stuff which blew up yeah yeah of
course the Duveen gallery in the bhishma
scene was hit by the Nazis destroyed the
day after the marbles had been moved
into the modern underground system yeah
so this they were just they're very
nearly no safe place and of course they
shouldn't be only in one was all their
partner and veneer was removed like
being cleaned with wire brushes barbaric
at not museum endeavour something like
twenty percent Christmas eum's never be
able to give a decent account of the way
it vandalized the marvels well they were
in its care so it's a it's a very boy
you examine the British case that they
helped to save them by taking away the
more shabby that case becomes let's move
on to another more portable piece let's
look at slide 15 and maybe Sharon could
talk a bit about this and yeah watching
yeah just to show you that I that that
this is a pretty complicated question
and I myself am NOT on one side of the
issue or the other this is a story that
I tell in the book about the return of a
cache of beautiful gold and silver
objects from the Lydian civilization is
referred to as the Lydian hoard and I'll
just try to give you a very summarized
story it's wonderfully colorful yarn but
basically there were there was a cache
about 360 pieces that were dug up and
smuggled out of the country and sold the
Metropolitan in the 1960s and kept in
their storerooms and never acknowledged
because they didn't quite you know they
were waiting to see if they could kind
of guide it quietly into their
collection without anybody noticing this
is at a time when these kinds of things
went on much more commonly than they do
today and there was a Turkish journalist
who's a character you'll meet in the
book if you read it I was going to jar
who had heard about this and there was
some leaks of this that had been out in
The Times of London and he spent 16
years dogging this story 16 years going
back to the town the small one-horse
town called a shock in central Anatolia
asking about it nobody would talk to him
no we want to talk about it little by
little they opened up he's a political
journalist he did this in a spare time
and then he actually was posted to new
york reavie I think it became a
freelance journalist in moved to New
York
that meant all the time to occasionally
to see if these pieces would ever show
up on display because he could never get
an answer out of the met as to whether
they had this cache called the Lydian
hoard or not and in fact in 1985 he was
visiting the museum and saw that they he
sawed up pieces that he recognized
because he had by that point he'd
already made very good contacts and good
friends for the townspeople who shocked
and they had described the pieces dim so
he knew exactly what he was looking for
and they were on display labeled a East
Greek treasure which is not actually
what they were the from the Libyan
civilization which is precede the Greeks
but anyway he flew back to Turkey took
the evidence to the Greek culture to the
Turkish culture ministry and Turkey
actually sued the Met for having
illegally bought smuggled treasures so
this became a call celebra was the first
major case a suit lawsuit under American
law of a major American cultural
institutions during the course of
discovery they found that in fact the
Board of Trustees have met knew
perfectly well who tell from the notes
of their meeting that they were buying
something that had been smuggled so
before anything went to court the met
cave they gave the Lydian hoard back and
it was returned to Turkey with great
fanfare lots of parties the President
himself opened the box and big press
conference children drew cartoons they
made balloons lots of people started
suing first asking for stuff back as a
result it was on display the Lydian
hoard was on display for two years in
Ankara before being sent back to this
town of a shock
history is beautiful where it belongs
this was a slogan that came that that
was sort of widespread in Turkey that I
was going to jar made popular and this
is the masterpiece one of two
masterpieces of the Lydian Hortis golden
hippocampus it's this big it's
absolutely beautiful and in 2005-2006
the story came out a small stream out of
the Turkish press that the masterpiece
of the Lydian hoard which by the way
that's an image that is printed every
day on the front page of the shock daily
paper so it's become a symbol of the
city and it's on their tourism brochure
and everything that this masterpiece had
been stolen from this one room Museum a
new shock
and that who was suspected in the theft
but the director of the Museum himself
we have the slide I don't know if we can
find him but there's a picture of a guy
in front of a glass case that's John
16:16 Kasim Kasim
go blue there he is thank you
the director himself that's him show in
standing in front of the case as you can
see that it's under if you can't see but
the lock at the very far left is
probably not as good as the lock is the
lock on my high school locker
it took an 18 to shoot a lock oh yeah we
said no that's yeah yeah that's the lock
those are the those are also two
bracelets also from the lady in horn
anyway Kasim was the guy who had gone to
New York he was deposed and you
explained I was so important that these
treasures come back to Turkey because
they were part of their cultural
identity and absolutely had to be back
at home where they were taken from Kasim
got divorced he ran up a lot of debts he
started gambling he started holding
parties in the museum with dubious
ladies and then he ended up it's like
the Getty yeah it's a little bit like
the Getty get his chapters in yeah yeah
toga parties at the Getty yeah so anyway
as you can see anyway he replaced it
with the counterfeits thinking nobody
would find it would find out but in fact
that one's about 10 grams heavier than
the original so guess what they found
out Kazem is now in jail the hippocampus
has disappeared the Mets been
embarrassed everybody loses that's
that's what sometimes happens when we
return stolen treasures to countries
that are not really capable of taking
care of what they have so that's just a
small morality tale to counterbalance
the you know post-colonial indignation
that some of us may have over what we
should return and not return there's
there's the realities of exhibition
preservation curation and what and and
the things that the great museums can do
that countries that don't have the same
resources may not be able to do is it
worth the risk is it worth the risk
what do you think you
I think it is why is that well if given
that one condition that I didn't get
universal agreement upon earlier is is
taken into consideration or called
atheist condition can be satisfied which
is it's it's emotional meaning to the
people involved very recent example
would be where she with in the United
Kingdom the Stone of Scone spelled
sparrin a historic coronation stone on
which would kneel the kings of Scotland
when Scott wasn't an independent was
taken by English conquerors to
Westminster Abbey and used in the
coronation of British Kings and English
kings it was stolen just before the
coronation of her present Queen by some
Scottish nationalists and taken away but
was recovered by the police and brought
back under a recent British government
has been returned to Scotland it's it's
part of the appurtenances of the new
semi-autonomous Scottish Parliament that
seems to me to make absolute sense it
means something to them it has a
continuous presence in their history
people would always have felt it
unnatural for it to be colonial or
Concord property do the good thing they
gave money and hoard back even though
was stolen well I mean you make you make
it make it hard for one to say that it
is yesterday mmm it's ready nicely I
would take even I think I just ask what
is the epoch of that jewelry it's about
twenty-five hundred years old it's
really it's very very beautiful it's and
it's also one of the many civilizations
that lie beneath the soil of Turkey that
really doesn't have a connection to
modern-day Turkish culture at all but
that's why I would take a contrary view
I mean I think I I do think there's
great empathy for the return of things
to people for whom those things still
have great meaning in fact in this
country we've we passed a law to require
museums to do that called Nagpur
national the Native American grave
Patriot Act so sacred things and and
human remains mostly in natural history
museums have been given back to Native
Americans when it can be proved in fact
that there is a connection between those
people that's partly because there's a
living relationship with those things
but the problem in most with most
ancient cultures around the world is
that these things Sharon mentioned that
there's it's there isn't a living
relationship with these things there may
be some national political pride in the
return of these that political probably
would probably be felt by those in the
dominant political position in Turkey I
don't think the Kurds in Turkey for
example would feel that same way and
when we identify something as Greek or
Italian or Turkish or were there long
enough jokes yeah
the Kurds yeah sure so you run into this
problem of ethno-nationalism of
something that is defining of national
culture on the basis of the dominant
power so if there were an immigrant and
that immigrant let's say came from
Central Asia who wasn't Turkic but he
came from someplace in Central Asia or
let's say it was an African but he feel
the same way toward these things or to
other kinds of things I think we're to
be very careful about racializing as
versed early racializing this thing it's
a it's a political construct of what is
cultural property it's not a scientific
one it's not a racial one its whatever
those in power in Turkey feel to be
their property they don't do the same
that were the Kurds for example you know
that isn't important to what it means
the power in Turkey thinks it means to
be Turkish what about looting looting
seems to be really that at the heart of
this whole thing when it comes to more
modern works how do you prevent looting
restitution does that stop looting or a
bar on trade yeah well I think how do
you stop looting it's a very good
question and that's really been the
subject of these lawsuits that we've
seen over recent more recent when I say
recent over things that were taken over
the past 40 years including the Lydian
hoard that's the kind of lawsuits that
we've seen that Italy has filed against
the Getty criminal truck and what's not
really a lawsuit what they've done
actually has played much more hardball
than just a lawsuit against an
institution what they've done is they
have criminal charges
that are against a former curator
herself so you have one curator Marian
true who's still still 1980 still today
on trial for charges of fraud and have
things having to do with having acquired
stolen antiquities for the Getty so you
have a career curator or
harvard-educated spent 24 years as an
esteemed member of the art art and
academic community did lots of great
things for Greece and Italy as their
partner and as somebody who had devoted
her life to that now finds herself on
criminal trial for having not lined her
own pockets but for having essentially
done her job the way she believed was
acceptable by the norms of the time more
or less
and so the Getty and this was done very
consciously by the Italian government as
leverage to get the Getty to return
pieces that they wanted back so it was
part of a campaign to stem looting and
smuggling from from Italy itself and I
think that it has succeeded in stopping
museums essentially from from buying
antiquities I think antiquities
collecting is down to a trickle at most
major museums you can counter much bad
if you think that's not true it's
certainly true with the Getty
statistically speaking and I think it
has stemmed looting in Italy and the
question is is there another way other
than because her you know Marion Truths
life is really ruined her careers ruined
her reputation is over she lost her job
and she's financially ruined as well so
I seems to me a particularly sad outcome
for a fight over two thousand or two you
know two thousand year old objects seems
very twenty-two hundred year old objects
very very sad and isn't there another
way but it has done looting and at the
same time looting is still absolutely
rampant rampant in Iraq in places like
Albania where there's very little
supervision places like Bulgaria it has
lots and lots of untouched
places where Greek treasures can be
found so looting goes on because people
want beautiful stuff and they always
will and there are measures to stem it
but I don't think you can ever cut it
off completely
what about countries like Turkey where
looting continues and just time to be
also in Italy just does that somehow
negate their rights to demand things
back if they can't keep track of their
own stuff well I think so actually yeah
I think if they can't keep truth they
can't control looting in their own
country then I think that they
completely undermine their own argument
that they ought to have things returned
to them that's my question about one of
them underlined and emphasized that with
the reference to the behavior of the
Turkish authorities in occupied Cyprus
in the island of Cyprus the the what
they call the footprints of civilization
the traceable evolution different humans
so is as long and continuous it's an
archeologist paradise almost as good as
China in that respect and see thousands
of years preceding an orderly way after
one another and after the illegal
Turkish invasion and occupation of the
northern tier of the island in 974 a
huge number of mainly green roses some
Armenian Orthodox churches with
wonderful icons and in systematically in
a very organized way just denuded that
anything of values is amputated and
taken out turns up on the other market
the government of Cyprus where it can
tries to buy these things by its rally
humiliating sometimes prosecutions can
be have been broad but in really it's an
international disgrace because all of
this is being done under the cover of
law by an actual recognized government
member the United Nations a candidate
member of the European Union and a
member of nature I think it should be
judged sanctions I mean the looting is a
very complicated situation because as
Sharon says as the Special Forces it's
no you know looting it's not an idle
pastime I mean it isn't a couple of
people with those metal detectors out
there you know on
and it's not a choice that one makes you
know they're not going to be a doctor or
looter you know it's it's a it's
typically because there are failed
circumstances and which one lives it's
either because your life has been ruined
by warfare sectarian violence by poverty
by corruption eking out a living in some
certain way the looters themselves are
not being rewarded as you know the the
organized crime people are who take from
the looters and so forth so we have to
realize that that stopping it at the
borders policing the site growing an
alternative economy all these things are
very very important to stop this and no
one condones looting it's the
destruction of knowledge it'll never be
restored once these things are wrenched
from the ground you've lost any
knowledge that could be gained from the
context in which they would have been
found and excavated but there once was a
practice that encouraged scientific
excavation and that was called portage
and that was comes with a French word
meaning sharing of things and from the
latter part of the nineteenth century
through the first half of the 20th
century foreign excavating teams mainly
from Europe and North America would
provide scientific expertise financial
resources employment like locally they
would excavate document the excavations
and share the finds with the local
authorities this is the way by which the
collections at the University of
Pennsylvania Museum at the University of
Chicago Museum many the collections of
metropolitan the British Museum and and
in Berlin Museum a in in Paris are
reformed but not just outside the found
that the country source countries it's
also how the Baghdad museum was created
the Kabul Museum the Cairo Museum the
local collections were also built the
same way with the rise of nationalism
that the end of the Ottoman Empire first
and then the end of the Second World War
secondly part OSH is all but stops
because there's a national claim a
political national claim on these
antiquities as being national cultural
property and that has prevented or
discouraged in any case the scientific
excavation of these sites and certainly
the sharing of these sites and has
concentrated the risk to the found
material again as I said earlier in one
place be a Baghdad be a Kabul or
wherever it might be so I think the rest
of restoration of part OSH which will
run counter to the
list resurgence but the rest the
restitute of a return of part Osment the
extremely important eNOS well then you
must be I mean I could but I do agree
with you and I was going to point out
myself that the Iraqi National Museum
was only made possible because of
British colonialism its Khurshid bells
idea the your oxygen havin ashes and
think of themselves having nationalism
or even a passionate or but then you
must surely be in favor of the idea of a
museum of the Acropolis the wishing
stars in which as far as possible
everything featuring to having to do
with the pertinence of said building and
so on is with the cooperation of British
government made it available to all and
wouldn't that be a classic instance of
what you recommend I think it's the
reversible commemoration museum would be
a co-sponsor but yeah it's all it's
returning these things to one place
rather than sharing these things between
places I'm arguing for sharing these
things between places not returning them
to a single place I think you know I I
first of all I've heard a lot of people
talk about the restoration of partage I
I can't really think of that that's a
bad idea except that except that it
looks backwards and I think that we have
to look forwards
we're in a very different world today
than we were in the 19th or 20th century
what cartagia's is a is archeology is
looking back with surely is one of the
least forward lines
I mean the United States always sounds
good to say no we should put this behind
us and move on
think of the future no but yes but not
way up here yes okay that's true that's
funny but what we're really talking
about it is what we're really talking
about about is possession and museums
well no no we're talking about access
not position it could be it could be
armed has to do with possess don't know
especially with access these things
could be lent they don't have to be I
understand that but the concept of
partage has to do with who gets to keep
the stuff who shares it part odd means
to share but the practice was when
looking forward we can talk about
sharing that's exactly what my point is
that we can take we can bring the good
aspects of what worked about part Oz and
incorporate that into new policies we
think about different ways of possession
or different arrangements that will
allow us to share more instead of being
on opposite sides of a tug of war which
is kind of where we're at now with
lawsuits and all that kind of thing
happening and people going to jail or
the threat of going to jail or the
threat of suspending excavation permits
but I don't believe that looking
backwards to is I've had many
conversations you know with the heads of
the great museums that we have talked
about this on other panels as well about
the ideals of the Enlightenment and what
museum with the great museums are really
about a universal museum I think that we
have to find new paradigms a new
language to talk about what is the right
thing to do with antiquities and how to
treat them and how to share them in a
global world in the 21st century that's
my only point okay and not to put you
even more on the spot I have to ask
about your collection at the Art
Institute of Chicago
are there any claims no on any of your
items no like you know I guess I could
be funny but probably dangerously so and
to say that that's an indication that we
had not been as ambitious a builder of
collections in the first part of the
20th century but it is the case we don't
have it claims against anything except
when the French are going to ask for the
suratha
yeah
what you explained what that is the
grounds job which is a painting that was
acquired by trustees of the Art
Institute of Chicago in the early part
of the 20th century how it can't you
know it would now not be possible to
remove that painting from France because
France has a law that would claim it as
French cultural property it didn't then
it listened to anything that was again
looted or surreptitious just it was
allowed to be purchased there all there
are reasonable laws that are for the
regulation of cultural property in the
world Britain has a very good one and
right now there's the great case of
course of the other Titian --zz with the
Duke of Sutherland and with the National
Gallery in the galleries of Scotland
together trying to buy this for their
and to share between those museums but
if there's a work of art that's judged
by a panel of British authorities to be
of great value to Britain it can prevent
the export of that objects let's say
that I wanted to buy it I'm going to buy
it for ten million dollars they could
hold export license for a period of time
that period of time is variable let's
say it's six months a year whatever it
might be allowing the British Museum or
consortium of British Museum's to raise
that equivalent amount of money that ten
million dollars for it to be returned to
remain within Britain so that so that
they kind of it's not a retention law or
it's not an open export law it's
something in between Japan has a very
interesting law as well by which it
categorizes objects as highest national
treasure national treasure you know near
to national treasure would like to be
Nationals right wherever they might be
you know going all the way down this
range you want to be necessary and it
doesn't allow the highest category of
thing to be exported in Japan but allows
percentages of each and greater
percentages as you decline down the
things so they do want there to be a
diaspora of Japanese objects the world
but they also want the right to claim a
portion of them as important to Japan
what are your policies on acquiring
artifacts
well and the first thing we have to do
is we have to inquire deeply into the
provenance of the object because we have
to adhere to national laws and so we
have to make sure we're first we have to
get as much information we can for the
person who's offering it to us whether
it's a dealer or whether it's a
collector or something we know how did
this object come into their possession
how to do come into this country tell us
all you can about the show is all in
documentation you have on that we then
have to try to decide from which country
it might have common and try to contact
those people we have to look through the
databases stolen property to do all this
research it has to be to confirm what
Sharon said it has had a chilling
effects on the acquisition antiquities
in this country it hasn't had a
consequence benefit to pur stopping
looting in the world but it has
prevented objects undocumented objects
or insufficiently documented objects
from coming in to public collections in
this country they have gone elsewhere
elsewhere not in Britain not in many
places in Europe but in the Middle East
in the Far East these things are being
looted they're going somewhere but
they're not coming into public
collections because that's collection
well they're I don't even think I mean
too many private collections country has
to be I don't think private collections
of this kind only more but I mean I was
in the I was in the Arabian Gulf in
Dubai United Arab Emirates recently and
it's just a it's a free it's a it's a
wild wild west over there you can buy
whatever you want there were in the main
hotel in Abu Dhabi this is a five
billion dollar hotel called the Emirates
Palace
there's just get between after the train
an obscene number of antiquities for
sale by actually a dealer based in
Beverly Hills but I spoke to some art
experts while I was there because I was
so shocked by what I saw I took pictures
of all of them because I every
imaginable civilization but the
conclusion was this stuff has to be fake
because there was so much of it it was
just absurd but maybe some of its fake
some of its not but not even it was
actually on display in the lobby of the
most of the sort of a marquee
center of the social world of Abu Dhabi
and they're constantly little news
releases of a shipment of smuggled art
intercepted at the Dubai customs and
that kind of thing when I was actually
when I was in Turkey interviewing the
the Minister of museums and monuments he
had just gotten a whole shipment of
stuff that had come from Turkey had was
stopped in Dubai he gave me this whole
sheaf of photographs of Antiquities that
had been smuggled out of Turkey from
Dubai and I said well you know why do
you think was in Dubai I really I don't
know they just seemed very it's a non
troppo Nina Burleigh is just done a very
interesting book about the
industrialized baking of Antiquities in
the Holy Land of Israel Palestine where
interestingly often the motive for
faking it is not just financial but is
to try and establish a nationalist or
racist or religious claim words here is
here is this box of remains that says
the Jesus family so that was you
actually I think the New York Times
almost fell for that story whether
you're so good this shows this shows
that this shows that shocked appalled
this shows that King this shows that
King David was a real person which means
we can build a settlement somewhere else
etc so there's a sort of triple layer of
corruption attached to it also shows how
gullible people are suppose we knew that
no I think it's it I sort of something I
became aware of as I was traveling
through the ancient world was how much
collecting excavating and displaying
artifacts is so closely tied to the
Nationalists to the National narrative
whatever that's meant to be and it made
me wonder how much gets ignored in the
excavation process as not serving kind
of the national myth whatever the
national myth might be and that I don't
know the answer to that question but it
did occur to me as I was reading about
the Hittites and the Hittite pact
between the Hittites and the Egyptians
and how the Israelite nation also had an
alliance there and I just thought gee I
never saw that reflected in any of
museums that I've seen in
or in Israel for that matter and I
thought well probably it's not very
convenient for the national narratives
of each of those countries today so
that's something else to kind of think
about always bearing in mind also that
every artifact in the Kabul National
Museum Afghan mushrooms you know in the
same week as the demolition of the
family I'm gonna throw me on Buddha's
was destroyed on purpose because it
didn't fit with me it's not a concept of
what a national catchment it would be of
this this stuff was by definition
profane because he didn't reflect the
Prophet so but thankfully they were
that's another reason why I think one of
us has to qualify this idea of are we
dealing with Assyrians or not or just
people who live where Assyria used to me
I think it's a good time to go to some
questions and the key thing is to go to
the mic because otherwise you won't be
heard or recorded so I think we'll set
up the mics there and if you could just
come up and as always keep the questions
brief and in the form of a question
we very appreciated and if maybe we
could yeah we took off the slot good
okay since you got there first go ahead
thank you
I'd like your panel to to answer or
comment on the looting that was done in
Baghdad when the American troops entered
anybody wanted I was actually in Baghdad
for used to work at the Washington Post
at the shortly after the Baghdad Museum
was looted and it's been very hard to
get the story straight because the story
that was put out at the time was 120,000
pieces were stolen and that was the
entirety of the Baghdad collection
Matthew buck da knows the American
colonel who was sent then to kind of set
things right
has done a very good job of explaining
what actually happened there are to my
knowledge still about four to five
thousand pieces that have not been
returned in fact so so it was so much as
much smaller number still horrible
number of a couple in or twenty thousand
something like that pieces many of the
most valuable pieces were thought stolen
it turns out were actually saved by the
museum staff and hidden in the bank
vault as by the way it was also the case
in couple the I just visited this
beautiful exhibit of the bactrian hoard
that was saved by these heroic heroic
museum staff in Kabul so they put it at
the risk of their own lives under the
Taliban in the Afghan in an Afghan Bank
but any event the main problem so there
are still about four or five thousand
pieces that are missing some of them
very valuable and singular pieces of
that museum to my knowledge but the
bigger problem I spoke recently about
the book in Washington and the Iraqi
ambassador came to that talk and he said
he confirmed to me what I've heard four
also from archeologists and such which
is that the looting going on in Baghdad
in Iraq generally is not having to do
with the museum but is extremely
destructive and rampant and uncontrolled
right now I have two questions on a
related topic deterrence first you
mentioned obliquely about punishment
and making looting a crime I was
wondering if you could talk about that a
little more and do we need to raise the
stakes to deter looting with punishment
and secondly are there any mechanisms
that exist to reward looting that is to
say give rewards to would be looters to
keep treasure or archaeological finds
inside - thanks this would be like
giving poppy farm or something else to
grow that kind of thing well there's an
awful lot of money out there from
museums and philanthropic organizations
to preserve yeah archaeological finds so
I don't know if there's any mechanisms
out there that exists well yeah no I
think that that's an important part of
what we're talking about earlier as a
part of the solution to the problem is
to create alternative economies because
this is a real economy in certain
situations so obviously there are means
of doing that it's on a scale and it
involves you know the investment that
governmental resources not museum
resources you know other but the scale
is so great would be on governmental or
non-governmental organization resources
but certainly that's part of it - the
question of the sort of penalties on
looting as a disincentive it generally
is and I probably as always everywhere
against the law to loot it's certainly
against the law to to remove in some
case against the law to own privately in
some cases against the law to to export
but there even in places where the
penalties are the greatest punishable by
death in China for example they're still
looting going on people still take risks
when they think there's a benefit to
them to take that risk
I mean people can you know commit all
kinds of crimes in this country because
they think they won't get caught
whatever the penalty might be so I don't
know the penalty by itself is sufficient
I think it's an integrated regime of
carrots and sticks it's going to make it
work the other thing is is that there's
no uniformity of penalties so and it's
wielded often for political reasons as
Jim has pointed out as in the case of
Marion truth
you have some very ambitious prosecutors
who've taken laws that have been on the
books in Italy that had met and not been
enforced pretty much forever and have
wielded that you know very aggressively
against for example Marian true but what
what is also the case is that there is
just a patchwork everywhere and there is
no international law there's no kind of
consistency to for people to either you
know adjudicate disputes or to know what
the what the penalties might be overall
and this and it so it makes it hard
because you know for example you now
have Egypt trying to pass a law that
would allow it to prosecute people the
same way that Italy has been and that
Greece has kind of done pretty sort of
half-heartedly so you don't really you
don't want to be tried in the Egyptian
judicial system I promise you on the
side yes over the Christmas holidays I
went to Cambridge the Fitzwilliam Museum
to see an extraordinary gold jewellery
which had been excavated in an area
called Vani which is now in the state of
Georgia
it was an amazing extraordinary exhibit
any rate they said that at the end of
its going to go to Greece and then it's
going to go to Los Angeles but after
that it's going back to Bonnie did those
people have a place where it can be kept
safe and share it with the rest of the
world I mean do they have a good system
for antiquities they're in in Georgia
I've never been to Georgia I really I
don't know I don't know I hope so this
but there's there's a so there's so many
incredible treasures in the area of the
former Soviet Union some of some of it
dates from the colonial period when they
took things for their own national
museums themselves
some of it is dates from World War two
and has to do with the stuff that Hitler
spent a lot of his time gathering up or
that very angry Soviet troops sort of
took in
triumphs back you know to to the mother
land and the Germany wants back from
Russia so you have all kinds of
restitution battles between Germany and
Russia today that has to do with objects
that originated in neither country so
but I don't know about the Georgia
Museum without knowing about that part
of the Caucasus it sounds as if they got
one idea very clear which is it's nice
to share and send things on the circuit
and if they don't have such a system now
well we've got to get soon that they are
as capable as anyone else of developing
what and it's clearly they respect their
patrimony so I think the answer is
provisionally yes it looks as if they
looks as if they are on the right track
I mean with anyway there's nope there's
no way of they won't get one unless they
are allowed to handle it themselves put
it like that thank you
I got a sense of how art museums are
being sensitive about what they may
acquire now what sort of
responsibilities do you think the art
auction houses have that they don't
bring pieces to the market that are hot
or otherwise inappropriately acquired
very good question I think that I think
the auction houses have an extremely
checkered history of that and when they
get caught then they stop so I think
that basically we you need to have
oversight and measures in place that
that keeps them from from you know
basically that you know their their
business to make money and so if they
get a beautiful object here for years
and years they would sell the objects of
Robin Symes for example the guy who was
involved with a lot of the Getty
purchases who has who was kind of at the
top of the art heap in the antiquities
world in the 80s and who's now kind of
vanished in a puff of smoke and he
worked very closely with the auction
houses and so I think that's a very
valid point they just have to be
monitored and governed like it like
everybody else because the temptation
and the money is so great so that when
they get an object that says owned by a
Swiss gentleman unnamed that's usually a
warning signal that that piece has no
provenance it might well have been
smuggled for example
sometimes it's undisguised in the case
of the little church byzantine church in
cyprus called kanakaria a real gem
replace very famous for his iconography
ii honor if he was stripped off and
turned up just under its own name in an
auction house in I think Austria I can't
remember there's a scandal that it
should even have been known a museum
would have dreamt of touching such a
thing that's quite clearly Stuart
property and it was also a terrible
desecration because it actually these
panels were prejudicial to the shape of
a certain part of the church and they
don't make any sense on there and
they're not really beautiful anymore
like the horse of Cellini puts on a sort
of dull plinth in the British Museum
especially looked at from below at a
certain point on the Acropolis it's
meaningless when it's been denatured
anyway I think one of the ways of
getting your carrot stick combination
better adjusted would be to remove the
incentive for looting that is supplied
by some of the more promiscuous or
auction houses just say you know you
won't make money this way I've spoken
very well about the issue as it relates
to art and architecture I was wondering
if there is any pressure for the return
repatriation of Egyptian mummies and I
asked that because the United States
when Native American remains are
involved there is intense pressure
either leave alone or return those
ancient remains and it makes a big media
splash but I haven't heard anything
about Egyptian or Russian or French
claims for it's very interesting I mean
I I myself I've had a couple of people
forward thinkers such as yourself asked
me that and what I've talked about the
book because there is there such a
debate over Native American remains and
and the proper disposition of those
remains I've not heard the a whiff
honestly of discussion of whether
displaying mummies is a desecration of a
corpse or of human remains from the
Egyptian point of view I don't know if
you you've read anything of the kind but
I've had a couple of young students say
well shouldn't this be you know
scandalous and I can't quite wrap my
head around that I mean lots of these
are 4,000 years old
and I mean in effect the fact that we're
showing King Tut's tomb is a desecration
of the ancient Egyptian religion these
things were never meant to be opened and
looked at by members of the public so I
think that's a discussion that's
probably been another turn of the wheel
or the evolutionary wheel if you like in
terms of how sensitive culturally
sensitive it's appropriate to be when
you're balancing knowledge and history
and understanding of the arc of human
civilization several years ago I was in
Addis Ababa and I was seeing the
skeletal remains of Lucy and then I
later I thought I was and then I later
found out that that is actually kept in
a vault when it's in that museum but
then it was traveling over to Houston
where it would be on public display so I
think this God the Son theme that's come
up in this discussion about whether
countries actually have a system to to
display things to the public is an
important one in that case it was great
that it was going to travel but my
question was a follow up on your comment
on Abu Dhabi because Thomas crenn's
spoke recently at Columbia about the
really great infusion of money of
investment into the art world I think he
said that the government of Abu Dhabi
was putting six hundred million dollars
now into contemporary art purchases and
at the Louvre and the Guggenheim and
others are starting to do these mega
museum projects though so could you talk
a little bit about when you have such a
very new investment do you see the
potential for more to happen in the in
the wrong direction as far as what you
mentioned you saw in the hotel there
yeah I'll come and be curious your Jim
has to say about this - first of all
having just finished a big piece on this
exact topic I can tell you that the
correct figure in Abu Dhabi is 27
billion dollars is what they're spending
to develop museums on Saudi Island 27
billion dollars to purchase 1.3 billion
is the Louvre Abu Dhabi alone and maybe
yeah that much for purchases for the
Guggenheim that content is working on
but I think having talked to the coastal
officials in Dubai and Qatar and Abu
Dhabi they have no
of any of these issues I really have
that strong feeling they are creating
probably 10 to 20 major world-class
museums by world built by world-class
architects at X 5 to 10 years it's going
to be a huge kind of shift in the
balance of power or is a kind of a place
for art and the world of art and culture
and among those that they're building
are so-called Universal museums which it
would be similar to at least in
principle a Louvre there will be an
actual Louvre of course you know British
Museum like the Met and so presumably
that means building antiquities
collections I don't think the problem is
if you're building contemporary art
collections then they'll just acquire
art like everybody else and they'll
borrow our for course from the Louvre
and that kind of thing and and benefit
from travelling exhibitions I don't know
if I did not get the sense that there's
anybody in that part of the world who's
thinking about the the you know the sand
traps that might await them in trying to
create an antiquities collection today
the only comparable museum that has had
that kind of ambition has been the Getty
in modern times and they've run into a
world of hurt in doing that so I think
that's definitely something to worth
asking about I don't know thank you
well I mean I think what Sharon said is
probably absolutely right I think there
are other interesting questions related
to it and that is to do with motivations
for this great investments in the arts
in that part of the world and of the
participating parties in it the louvre
as you know is a part of the cultural
Ministry of France and and it is a
political arm of the government as it
were and it was very clear when the
cultural minister announced this
relationship that the French wanted the
Louvre to be there because they wanted
to have a player in the game in that
part of the world you know recognizing
that the British in the US were there on
other terms at that time military and
economic let's say the French wanted to
be at the table and they were going to
be at the table on cultural terms have a
presence it was a it was a frank
statement of the politicization of this
and of this activity becomes of the
Guggenheim you know it's part of the
business
and the Guggenheim as far as I can tell
I don't know it in detail but it's it's
not it's not for why we might wish that
this was happening we might wish that it
was happening because it was going to be
bringing the world's cultures
representative examples of the world's
culture together in one place to build
understanding among Arab peoples and non
Arab peoples in the world to the greater
glory of humankind you know it does seem
to be that as Christopher said it's a
non troppo the ambition is to create
what I understand people who've gone
there to see it the people who are
coming into the museum for whom the
museum might be built or not local
people for the most part they're people
they're creating destinations cultural
destinations tourist destinations hotels
golf courses you know things that are
relevant to an ultra poor so I think a
larger question in addition to Sharon's
questions is really what is the
motivation for doing this make us the
last question thank you
what are the five antiquities that Egypt
would like back from the West and
whether status about what is the status
of going back so the Rosetta Stone at
the British Museum the zodiac ceiling
which you saw which is at the Louvre the
best of on Hoth which we have about TQM
social slides it's at the number six
this we're going to show sticks we
should also show five because it would
you can see that he's in the British
Museum of the Boston sorry the Boston
Museum of Fine Arts and was one of the
architect of one of the the great
pyramids of the second large pyramid on
and there's yeah we looked at five I
think you'll see where he came from so
he was he was taken legally from here in
a sanctioned dig the 20s but he would be
put back where he was was laid to rest
in full view of this magnificent
monument that he built and then there's
and there's of course three major
pyramids there everybody those so
there's the bust of ham you know who
designed the Great Pyramid is four and
five forty I'm missing Thank You Boston
opportunities all the other cover the
book Horseman touch
what if instead of a slide you have that
thank you yes nice thank you for the
reminder who is in Berlin and the status
of them is the official request is that
they be loaned for three months for the
opening of a new museum which Egypt so
desperately needs that they're building
at the foot anybody's been to the Cairo
Museum would know that they're building
it in the in the region and the environs
of the pyramids the bust of on Hoth
Boston has said no the Boston home you
know Hilde song has said yes they will
loan it the bust of Nefertiti has been
deemed too fragile to travel I don't
really believe that but anyhow that's
what they're saying I think but I
actually think they might be meeting to
discuss it but there I don't think
they've officially rejected the idea but
they have said it's two-truck fragile to
travel the zodiacs ceiling is considered
too fragile to travel and the rosetta
stone is I think that there it's under
consideration that's the latest
okay thank you very much
Oh
HR will be downstairs signing books